the lefty kyle freeland a 17-game winner
two seasons ago fridlin last year was a
major disappointment but now enjoying a
bounce-back season oh two swinging and a
missed ball in the dirt
walters tagged him out and that'll take
care of things three pitches and a punch
out for kyle freeland hot smash handled
it third by arenado long throw to first
he gets him well that ball had some pace
on it nolan makes a fine play two quick
outs and now all of a sudden you have
the bases loaded for a talented switch
hitter in eduardo escobar oh one to
escobar is a high fly ball to shallow
left
coming in is rimel tapia he's got it no
damage done for kyle freeland zach
gallon talked about making an impression
since he arrived briefly in miami and
then in arizona 281 this year he's made
18 consecutive starts to begin his
career without allowing more than three
earned runs
it's hampson on three pitches back to
the curve ball strikeout number one
got him inside with a fastball gallon
gets the strikeout and he struck out the
first two well he certainly had him
looking away
marinado got under that fastball tim
lacastro is in right field
makes a catch and that's
the ending no runs one hit one left
after one in denver kelly needs to get
his back going he's knocked in three but
he's only five for 32 at the plate he
has walked five times oh one carson
kelly nice pickup by nolan and a perfect
throw nolan making the play look easy
yeah he sure did good backhand pick and
then knew that kelly was running doesn't
possess great speed was able to set
himself take a moment
and a ground ball to nolan easy play
and the bloop double does no damage they
have stranded four the diamondbacks no
score middle of two mcmahon is hitting
200 he's 10 for 50 most alarming he has
struck out 22 of those 50 times to the
play and a swing and a miss that's why
he struck out now 23 times
jason ball with the dirt third strikeout
for gallon two quick outs here in the
second here's the o2 pitch he had a
swing of the miss he just challenged
with a fastball didn't get it four
strikeouts and two innings for zach
gallon tony walters to step in left-hand
hitting catcher here comes the 2-2
and the bat goes flying zach got in
there with that cutter and gets his
fifth strikeout one away in the third
trevor story drive this one deep to left
center starling is there so nice job by
zach gallon keeps the rockies off the
board we'll head to the fourth christian
walker leading off against kyle fralen
comes in with a fastball and walker
sends it way out of here
there's number one in 2020 for christian
walker and the diamondbacks grab a
one-nothing lead 2-1 offering swung on
and popped way up in the air on the
infield back of the play walters moving
towards the first base
dugout makes the catch rockies down one
nothing here's nolan this ball's driven
to center field and deep's got a chance
it is gone
two round nolan orenado home run and the
rockies take the lead in the fourth big
shot for nolan his fourth homer of the
year and the rockies have two aboard
with two down in the fourth two and two
with two outs
and here comes the runner from third and
mcmahon is out at home
gets himself thrown out at home plate to
win the inning top of the order now and
andy young who is over two he's
strengthened grounded up
and he'll hit it sharply nolan to his
left dives gets up throws across got him
andy young playing in just his sixth big
league game got a taste of what gold is
like could tell marta with a one-one
count
and this is chopped up the middle trevor
is gonna have to hustle got it that's
the leather boys
seven pitch inning and here's walker who
hit the long homer not going and a
double play ball
good feed good throw two out with nobody
out they decided not to send the runners
and freeland got a big double play
grounder
line drive right at story inning over
now we go to the seventh it's still two
on rockies each team with their runs in
the fourth very well-pitched ball game
right here carson kelly trying to get
his first of the year and carson kelly
has tied it up loud contact on that one
by carson you know had had to feel good
no doubt about that one
and this is out in front of the plate
kyle's got it kyle throws a fastball to
murphy nba now here comes escobar he'll
ban left-handed against estevez with two
on and two out two-two
swag and a miss he got him with a change
up
throwing 97 he gets a punch out with a
change and the rockies are in business
here in the bottom of the eighth
and this is in a right center field it's
going to drop
hampson scores on the base hit by story
three to two colorado nobody out charlie
blackman at the plate
this is a high fly ball deep center
field did charlie get enough of it
off the very top of the wall again
here's story coming home
double for blackfin safe at the plate is
trevor 4-2 rockies still nobody out in
the eighth
murphy ground ball through the right
side blackman around third he's coming
home
5-2 colorado
five straight have reached here at the
bottom of the eighth now champion of the
plate
and toppy off the end of the bat this is
floating to shallow center it's going to
drop
arana will score now murphy getting a
green light he's coming around daniel
will score
topia fly ball double and now the
rockies lead it by five
there's a base hit to left come on down
rymel tapia tony walters getting
involved 8-2 colorado it's been a
four-run ninth inning for the d-backs
one-on-one is driven to right field and
that is down for a base hit
marshall digging for third they wave
starling and it's a one-run ball game
strike three ball game over
take a big
big deep breath everyone